même si j'avais été en tort
embrouillez-vous en public avec un
handicapé il y a peu de chances que vous
entendez donc de toute façon je pouvais
aller au bout voilà
nickel j'irai mieux bonsoir bonsoir
alors Roland-Garros vient de démarrer et
une fois de plus le public et les
commentateurs vont railler les joueurs
français face au star du circuit et
pourtant on a un Français capable de
faire mordre la poussière à tous ces
adversaires vainqueur de Roland-Garros
médaille d'or aux Jeux olympiques de
Pékin il s'appelle Michael Jeremias
les joueurs pro de tennis en fauteuil
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à
20h
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes né le 15 octobre 1980
à Paris dans le 12e arrondissement vous
êtes le deuxième d'une famille de trois
enfants perd cardiologue mère prof
d'espagnol très tôt vos parents vous
mettent au sport le ski à deux ans et le
tennis à 5 ans et vous faites des
progrès rapides mais vous devenez de
plus en plus casse-cou ou pratiquer le
ski hors-piste le ski acrobatique vous
aimez vous dépasser en faisant de la
vitesse des sauts des figures voilà
c'est d'éprouver un petit peu aux autres
que je peux aller un peu plus loin donc
qui est un adolescent un peu con qui
veut impressionner les copains qui va
faire le saut de trop qui va faire le
shoes de trop leur piste de trop et
voilà mais tout en contrôlant
jusqu'au 7 février 2000 là c'est
l'accident comme tous les ans notre
famille au grand complet est en vacances
à Avoriaz et après le déjeuner le temps
se couvre donc les parents rentrent et
vous vos frères et vos cousins vous
partez au snow par Ark un endroit
réservé aux amateurs de sensations
fortes
après quelques descentes votre grand
frère vous propose un concours de saut
et là vous êtes 5 vous lancez des défis
vous faites monter l'adrénaline ça peut
être bon pour cette psychanalyse mais
moi je l'ai branche les blanchi depuis
c'est pas sa faute et mon frère veut
nous dit moi et mon meilleur pote notre
ami d'enfance dernier saut aujourd'hui
vous allez être en forme on va regarder
en bas de la bosse celui qui fait le
plus haut et le plus beau mon pote
s'élance fait deux bossaux moi je
mélange simplement j'ai pas freiné entre
les deux je voulais justement les battre
impressionner mon grand frère mais aussi
mon petit frère qui était là et là je
suis parti à 7 8 mètres de haut en
arrière comme un pantin vous dites je
n'atterris jamais un coup de poing dans
le ventre me coupe la respiration je
perds connaissance le trou noir
les secours arrivent avec un traîneau
vous avez les deux jambes cassées mais à
l'hôpital le diagnostic s'aggrave c'est
les deux fémur plus la deuxième dorsale
diagnostic je connais pas tout de suite
finalement des fractures de fémur c'est
pas très grave ça se considère par
contre fracture dorsale
je suis donc paralysé des membres
inférieurs voilà votre père lui il
comprend tout de suite mon père médecin
lui au centre de soins qu'on voit les
premiers radios lui c'est déjà ce que ça
veut dire et donc beaucoup plus dur pour
lui à ce moment-là vous êtes opéré en
urgence à Genève 9 heures de
reconstruction des plaques des vis des
agrafes et au réveil vous êtes sous
morphine donc vous vous rendez pas
compte en fait vous imitez Brando dans
le parrain et vous dites il faut aller
détruire ce snowparc enfin vous vous
rendez compte de rien en fait je m'en
souviens même pas c'est ce qu'on raconte
mes parents mes frères il leur demande
d'aller détruire la Bose d'aller tuer
celui qui a construit la bosse je les
rassure à ce moment là je les rassure
alors que voilà se pose toutes les
questions du monde c'est à Paris en fait
que vous reprenez conscience et là vous
vous sentez rien vos jambes vous brûlent
j'ai essayé ces fameuses douleurs
fantômes qui ont les personnes
paralysées ou les personnes amputées les
douleurs neurologiques ou j'ai
l'impression d'avoir mal aux pieds alors
je sens plus mes pieds donc du nombril
jusqu'à mes pieds je ne sens rien au
départ en fait ce qui vous angoisse plus
que vos jambes c'est votre entrejambe
parce que pendant plusieurs semaines
vous vivez dans l'espoir d'une érection
qui n'arrive pas et qui finira par
arriver oui un matin trois semaines je
lève le drap et là une belle érection
bien fière bonne nouvelle voilà une
bonne nouvelle et ça fait ça
ça je t'interroge beaucoup les gens les
gens pensent que le plus important
finalement quand j'ai 18 ans c'est de
remarcher mais très sincèrement à 18 ans
vous très rapidement on pose la question
est-ce que vous allez plaire est-ce que
vous allez avoir une sexualité normale
plutôt que de remarcher alors ensuite
comment se la rééducation là vous
finissez par accepter de partager la
chambre d'un tétraplégique prénommé
Philippe et c'est lui qui vous initie au
pétard quoi lui gros consommateur mais
simplement tétraplégique peut pas servir
d'une pipe et donc m'a appris à rouler
la pipe m'a préparé son chef à lui
rouler ses joints et donc en fait du
matin au soir on fumait ensemble et le
deal c'est qu'il me fournissait en
cannabis simplement moi je devais lui
rouler pour la journée lui préparer le
matin à sa pipe voyons regarder les
informations le matin les aides
soignants étaient évidemment au courant
nous laisser tranquille j'ai plus pris
de petit déjeuner depuis ce depuis cette
rencontre avec Philippe là vous allez au
fond du parc et puis vous fumez quoi
tous les soirs on se rencontrait avec
les amputés les grands brûlés les
paraplégiques tout ça on allait on se
partager notre site tous les soirs tous
les activités terminées lis
aide-soignantes s'en aperçoive elle vous
dit j'en connais un qui vient de fumer
une espèce de bienveillance autour de ça
ils savent que ça fait partie d'une
certaine manière de la de la rééducation
on a besoin de ça aussi un peu de
s'évader parce que c'est une période
difficile et puis un jour vous demandez
à votre mère de vous rapporter votre
raquette de tennis et des balles et vous
commencez à jouer contre le mur de la
chambre jusqu'au jour où le prof de
tennis du centre vous parle de tennis en
fauteuil ah bon je découvre donc j'ai
tapé mes premières balles quelques mois
après un accident sur un fauteuil de
basket voilà moins d'un an après vous
disputez les championnats de France de
tennis en novembre 2001 je suis champion
de France de tennis handisport
alors
le problème c'est quand même toujours le
sexe il y a une petite infirmière très
mignonne sur laquelle vous flashez vous
n'êtes pas trop lui parler malgré le
signaux de séduction vous êtes pas sûr
que elle capte le message et ça sera
fait le jour votre frère arrive avec un
copain dans votre chambre avec du scotch
et il colle sur toute la chambre des
pages de magazine porno donc la fille
elle comprend là sauf que sauf que c'est
évidemment pas la meilleure manière
c'est dur qui que ce soit je vous dis à
tous et en fait c'était surtout un moyen
pour mon frère et mes potes comme
d'habitude de m'embarrasser et donc
l'infirmière en question est arrivé et
donc là ça évidemment brise la glace
mais pas mais ça n'a pas vraiment excité
plus autre mesure
en fait que le fauteuil peut attirer
autant que repousser les filles et vous
commencez à multiplier les conquêtes des
infirmières des aides soignantes des
kinés et puis ensuite dans les boîtes et
puis dans le milieu du tennis
effectivement ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez une sexuelle parfaitement
normal quoi le truc c'est que je me
rends compte que quand vous allez dans
un lieu public qui est en l'occurrence
une boîte de nuit vous n'êtes pas
anonyme
vous remarque puis moi quand j'arrive au
bar vu que je peux mettre debout je peux
rappeler bah il y a la place la glace
qui est brisée quand on voit mettre
debout mais comment ça se fait qu'il
peut te mettre debout et puis ça y est
il y a pas il y a pas à faire tout ce
baratin quand vous sortez voilà regardez
de loin faire votre les murs rien avec
votre petit verre d'alcool non vous y
allez et puis vous dites franchement
j'ai mon accident l'année dernière il y
a bien plus grave que d'avoir peur que
la fille disent NON et tout il y a une
accroche il y a une vraie curiosité en
plus autour de ça alors après plusieurs
mois de rééducation vous rentrez chez
vous et là vous découvrez les vrais
rapports entre les personnes handicapées
le reste du monde nous appréhendez le
jour de la rentrée à la fac de Créteil
et d'ailleurs vous arrivez là ce matin
là vous roulez un moment il y a un trou
dans le sol rouge m'éclate par terre
chose qui m'arrive quand même très très
rarement et là très rapidement je vois
s'il y a personne qui me regarde parce
que c'est gênant et puis là je vois ce
gars là qui me regarde qui a une dizaine
de mètres il me fixe
et puis tourne la tête et puis s'en va
et je sais pas à ce moment là évidemment
j'attendais autre chose ne serait-ce que
ça va est-ce que je peux faire un coup
de main et j'essaie de le rattraper mais
le temps de remonter sur feuille et tout
je l'ai je l'ai jamais rattrapé donc
qu'est-ce que j'avais à lui dire la si
vous regarde explique-moi qu'est-ce qui
pourquoi est-ce que tu as eu peur est-ce
que tu étais gêné il y a une histoire
dans un bar aussi dans le 11e un bar à
la mode vous commandez à boire vous
levez donc et une fille qui vous dit tu
crois vraiment que c'est la solution je
regarde comme ça je fais pardon elle
réinsiste elle jouait vraiment que le
verre d'alcool choque et donc là on part
dans une espèce d'embrouille mais
qu'est-ce qui vous prend vous êtes qui
pour me juger pour oublier votre malheur
exactement et donc là je le vis comme
une vraie agression et ça se termine mal
parce que je me sens agressé
devant tout le monde mais en lui faisant
un peu mal en lui serrant le bras parce
que je vivais ça comme une agression
elle me fait passer pour l'handicapé
gris ce qui était horrible ce qui a
intensifier peut-être la pression puis
ça s'est terminé avec son copain qui a
voulu faire la justifier que j'ai un peu
violenté en le poussant et puis mon
frère comme mes frères qui qui les ont
viré dehors quoi les vigueur de la boîte
qu'on connaissait quoi d'ailleurs ils
ont pas le choix même si j'avais été en
tort embrouillez-vous en public avec un
handicapé il y a peu de chances que vous
entendez donc de toute façon je pouvais
aller au bout de mon cœur
alors
constatons votre intérêt pour le tennis
en fauteuil votre père décide de vous
emmener voir la finale de la Coupe du
monde et vous lui dites tu vois tous ces
mecs là un jour je vais les battre ils
ont souri ils ont souri parce que
la grande gueule il arrêtera jamais mais
aussi bah tiens un petit challenge
intéressant et effectivement quelques
années plus tard je les ai tous battus
bah oui alors le premier match officiel
vous gagnez malgré le fait que vous
soyez en fauteuil de ville et fauteuil
de ville c'est comme faire une course de
Formule 1 en 4L quoi c'est à peu près ça
j'ai débuté j'avais pas encore monté de
sport ça coûte très cher un fauteuil de
sport et donc l'adversaire me met la
pression et je le bats finalement 6-060
alors
là c'est parti 2005 numéro un mondial
2005-2006 vainqueur en double à l'US
Open 2008 médailles d'or en double aux
Jeux olympiques de Pékin 2016-2019
vainqueur en double à Roland-Garros il y
a donc un Français qui gagne à
Roland-Garros il est avec nous ce soir
la big up
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous jouez vous jouez contre des
valides mais oui c'est notre grand truc
de défier notamment les grands les
grands champions
je le connais depuis qu'il a 5 ans et un
jour Roland Garros de manière un peu
improvisée on s'est dit viens on tape
quelques balles donc on a joué il y a
plein de gens qui sont venus nous
regarder c'était super c'était assez
impressionnant parce que ça allait très
vite puis il a commencé à me faire
rouler dans tous les sens il a commencé
vraiment à mettre mal je fais ok pas de
problème j'avais un autre fauteuil
roulant de sport il s'est mis dedans et
là je l'ai évidemment écrasé quelqu'un
qui qui jouait au tennis comme ça
il a joué le jeu voilà et puis dans
trois semaines vous vous mariez avec
Caroline c'est ça qui est une kiné donc
vous avez
une anglaise avec qui vous êtes depuis
trois ans c'est ça donc finalement cette
histoire c'est terrible ce que je vais
dire mais cette histoire c'était bien
finalement mais c'était bien c'est à
dire qu'à part le côté souffrance de
l'accident faire souffrir les proches
évidemment parce que c'est dur pour eux
voilà s'il y a un prix à payer moi
aujourd'hui je change pas la vie que
j'ai avec celle que j'aurais
éventuellement pu avoir c'est sûr je
suis heureux fauteuil ou pas voilà puis
je me réalise dans tous les projets que
je fais
alors
Gaspard vous avez des Vans sur les
handicapés dans votre spectacle ouais un
peu ouais
[Rires]
juste dit que je me suis déjà mis à la
place d'une personne handicapée ce qui
est vrai sa place de parking en tout cas
vous avez eu le premier mot le mot de la
fin non c'est formidable parce que tout
le monde n'a pas relève pas le défi
comme il l'a relevé j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on a tous rendez-vous avec notre
liberté pourquoi il veut pas échanger sa
vie c'est parce qu'il a conquis sa
liberté et il l'a fait lui et il la rend
à tout le monde très beau mot de lapin
voilà merci et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu